اما قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني حسين
سلامي فقال ان بلاده ستلاحق العدو في اي
مكان من العالم اذا تعرضت السفن الايرانيه
في البحار
لادمعتداء وظف سلامي في كلمه له ان طهران
تمتلك مسيرات قادره على التاثير على
العديد من الممرات البحريه الاستراتيجيه
في العالم
صواريقه الى عمق الارض الايرانيه ايا كان
مداها نحن لا نغامر بامن الدول الاخرى
لاجل ضمان امنا القومي ولا نهدد احدا
لكننا ندافع عن مصالحنا والامن المشترك
بين الجميع دول المنطقه
الملاحه اننا اليوم هي الخطوط التي تعبر
منها صفوف ترفع العلم الايراني لان العدو
يعلم ان ناسا لاحقا في اي مكان من العالم
في حاله ان اعتداء على سفينه في البحار
نمتلكم سيارات تعمل بالذكاء الصناعيه
الوصول الى اي نقطتين في المحيطات وعلى
مدن كبير جدا ليس من ضروري ان نذكره وهذه
المسيارات تؤثر في العديد من الممرات
البحريه الاستراتيجيه في العالم